the racers were ready at dawn very
tense in some circles King of the
Hammers is a far far better thing than
the Super Bowl the Kentucky Derby and a
Kim Kardashian nft drop all rolled into
one this race attracts a very special
breed whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa piss
off
[Music]
it was time to get grounded to ponder
this rotten assignment and figure out
how to cope with it 7 Days In The Deep
desert surrounded by Madness and Anarchy
king of hammers it's race day y'all hell
even the grandmas here make Burning Man
look like a bunch of
[Music]
grandmas those of us who had been up all
night were in no mood for lattes and
sausage rolls
we wanted strong drink we were after all
the absolute cream of Internet travel
log
influencers we were gathered here in the
desert of Johnson Valley California to
witness the spirit of invention in its
most feral form when it comes to a thing
like this you don't fool
[Music]
around
[Applause]
[Music]
the man driving this Beast of a vehicle
is Shannon
Campbell he's 53 has very poor vision
and has won King of the Hammers three
times
very he's an absolute racing Legend and
you're about to see why
[Music]
look at Shan in a complete roll lands on
the tires and keeps on
going you or I might be traumatized by a
near-death experience like
that but not
Shannon had a good run going up on top
and uh I stuffed it and it kicked the
fuel pump out or something what about
when you
flipped up that was is that scary though
it's got to be no I
mean scary is when it doesn't get land
on
[Laughter]
it things you should know about King of
the
Hammers it's a 10-day event that takes
place in the Southern California desert
there are a series of races for
different types of off-road
vehicles also Mayhem chaos and very few
rules totally normal thing to
do this year 80,000 Maniacs
attended revelries commence with the
time
trials and climax with the race of Kings
a 200m course that requires drivers to
conquer rocks and to drive at incredibly
high speeds across the desert it's
basically impossible so it attracts the
kind of people who like
impossible people like Bailey Campbell
who headed into race week as a serious
Contender for the crown I got my whole
family out here uh my dad my brother my
husband how many years have you done
this this will be my eighth King of the
Hammers eth
okay the Campbell are a racing family
there's Bailey's brother whand and
you've already met dad
Shannon and she married a fellow speed
fiend as well is that your husband back
from the track yeah money it was so
smooth I got it by 6 seconds we watched
it yeah for Bailey though things aren't
going so smoothly with only a few
precious days before the Big Race Bailey
has just found out that her vehicle is
in need of big fixes I mean I know
vehicles are always kind of fickle and
everything this is normal or no it's not
no um this is probably the worst repair
we've had to do out here yeah I will
call you later tonight when you guys are
ready to go through UTV parts to dispers
stre pits you're going to run home try
to fix it and then try to get back by
Friday
yeah wish you a lot of luck back here
thank you okay thanks and just like that
Bailey is wondering if she'll even be
able to
race a lot of the competitors are like
her passionate Scrappy barely holding
their cars together
[Music]
then there are folks like Jason Sherer
we have enough ground clearance to
literally get our tire between this rock
and
this Jason is one of this year's
favorites like Shannon he's won King of
the Hammers three
times 75% of people don't finish this
race finishing it's an a Monumental task
and an achievement right and you feel
good after if you do it but once you've
won it finishing it is no longer the
goal it's only winning it again old if
the Campbell are a DIY Family Affair
Jason is a polished professional with
money a big team and a Decked Out
vehicle I was wonder if we could geek
out a little bit on the car well this
car was a fun one to build so I spent
the last 2 and 1/ half years designing
it on a computer before we ever started
cutting the first
tube this thing really does have it all
an engine with enough horsepower to top
a 150 mph on the desert
straightaways shocks that can basically
see what's coming before it hits you a
hardened underbelly to make sure rocks
don't shoot up into a fuel tank or your
thigh and lar and GPS to help find that
perfect route through the Rocks so as
you can say it says big rock on the GPS
right now which basically describes the
whole place still even with all the
bells and whistles Jason has to put his
body through this race like everybody
else what the is it like when you're in
the car I mean it looks insane you know
it's full punk
rock it is brutal it is it is a pounding
I would get my kidneys to bleed um I I
would get blood in my mouth while we
were driving and feel it when I started
and I didn't think I was driving hard
enough unless I had that feeling what
Jason is describing is the the law of
internal organs which says they tend to
stay in motion even after your body has
slammed into rocks at high
speeds and that's just the physical
[Music]
part love it God is so hard to
do isn't I like crying in there you it
might be Ah that's
embarrassing
I thought it was touching
man damn it that was funny
though one thing's for sure it's a hell
of a rush
man I need one more I need to know that
I was the best here and and if I never
finish another one but I got one more
win I'll be totally content and nobody's
won four nobody's won four right yeah I
want to be the first
one hang around these guys long enough
and you you too will start to feel the
itch time to get my organ
shook where do this go right there all
right here we
[Music]
go that is crazy
[Applause]
man that's what I came here
for it makes no
sense it was awesome it doesn't make any
sense
man why like like it's fun as but why
would anyone do this
sounds awesome I was shaken rattled and
Delirious which is to say can we do it
again I have good
news we have found the spot where dreams
come
true now you
[Music]
know after the time trials the teams
regroup do some work on their cars and
make their plans for the big
race since I tragically did not have a
car of my own to fix it was time to
explore this is hammertown where most of
of the onlookers
[Music]
stay about a 10-minute drive away just
outside of the thick of
things there is laser
town it's where the the Riff Raff who
want to get away from the Riff Raff come
spend the
[Music]
week there are people who like King of
the
Hammers and then there's Cody who loves
it so much he decided to build his own
private Oasis we actually have 40 acres
now right next to the
race uh we are having a large uh uh fire
uh Friday night and Saturday night so uh
if you guys are around or if you're not
you can probably see it from anywhere
but don't call the authorities if you
see a structure fire cuz it's probably
us it has everything a man in no man's
land could want art first you got to
play with him a little bit a koi pond
that's Sunny he's a
pig and of course a luxurious home made
out of shipping containers that's not
what I
expected that's the
point there's even room for a couple
hundred close friends it's kind of
turned into a campground we'll call it
yeah and uh do you have to like feed all
these people or they offend for
themselves no they fend for themselves
they just I just provide the
[Music]
dirt they might be building cities from
scratch these
days but to hear an OG like Shannon tell
it things were very different when the
race first started back in 2007 I mean
we started out way back in the day just
rock crawling for fun you know friends
going out and hill climbing and you know
back then there was a whole lot of uh
alcohol and fun involved but this a has
grown so much from when it was a few of
you guys around a fire you know doing
your own thing to now 880,000 people
that was the good days when it was just
very simple and you know you weren't out
here for you'd show up for a couple of
days for this race and now we're here
for two weeks and I don't know how long
you've been here but I'm ready to get
the hell out of here I breathing
dirt sitting there the day before the
main event sipping of Bloody Mary made
by Bloody Mary Larry oh yeah Bloody Mary
Larry makes the best thank you Larry
Shannon's mind was on his daughter and
her car she's tough she'll get over it
but I mean it kills her cuz she's
literally been working on her car since
the last race just I mean polishing it
looking everything over you know just
anything she can do to make it better
and and be perfect when she got here and
then you know it it doesn't take
anything to take you out you know and we
haven't even got to the race
yet with the race approaching it was
time to meet some more
contenders I'm sometimes PG I'll try to
keep it pg3 you don't have to you can do
whatever you want we do it
all all right the Gomez brothers are one
of those teams that make other Racers
sweat there's Marcos JP and last year's
winner
Raul they operate a booming tree
clearing business in Northern California
and funnel a portion of their Good
Fortune into this ridiculous Hobby and
I'll in for this whatever week 10 days
is between the vehicles and the team and
just the living stuff I mean how much do
you think it costs to be here for this
race so if they went to buy a car like
this you're spending 350,000 for 350,000
400,000 just to like buy one just to buy
the car okay just the tire is $1,200 the
wheel's $900 and it's it just adds up
and you're spending $500,000 to come do
this thing yeah give it a go cool a a
real competitive go yeah there we go
there a difference if you want to come
out and trail ride around and get ran
over that's a difference
story just look for k86 that's me mar
Gomez for I'll be on the podium tomorrow
thanks guys thanks spoiler alert this is
not how it played out for
Marcos but his brother
Raul well we'll get
[Music]
there oh no
as with any town in
America there's life during the day oh I
really am bad dude Jesus and then
there's what comes after what do you
guys do at night uh go up to Chocolate
back door watch the rock crawlers and
the Carnage and just hang out yeah drink
beers and hang
out yeah
[Music]
it's human Mario Kart that's what it
is where are we we're on like Thursday
of this thing every night it's like a
different party this one is in the place
they call the back door I feel like it's
mostly a party for cars more than it's a
party for
people a party for cars what could go
wrong
[Music]
I don't think I've ever seen anything
like this I don't know how to describe
how many people are up in these Hills
with these cars still driving through
with now fire coming out of
them how you feeling there's a lot of
testosterone in
here oh look out look out look
out
oh dude
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus moments later windows were smashed
and the reckless driver found himself on
the wrong end of an angry mob H
[Music]
man it's the kind of scene that makes
you think this event might not be around
forever it's grown so much I mean how
much more can it grow before California
says get out of our state you
know now what breaking his windows over
there getting him out the car breaking
his
window it's just gotten so crazy that
you get outside that gate and it's
dangerous people are walking around out
there and and you know drunks wrecking
stuff and wrecking into
people well cuz you kind of feel like
you're a Disneyland or it's like a it's
not it's not real life you know cuz it's
it's so it's hard to control there's
just too many
people I don't see it getting any
smaller that's for sure it's it's going
to blow up until someone's says we're
done get out of
[Music]
here
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to King of the Hammers it is the
big day we've been watching races all
week long motos desert Challenge and
here we are at the race of Kings I know
I got to
share
it's race
morning all the drivers are lining
up my heart is kind of pulling through
the cbles
today the family's mechanical woses
continue Bailey's attempts to fix her
car were unsuccessful her brother
Wayland also saddled with vehicle issues
they've decided to share a car and each
take a lap Bailey will be the first
woman to drive in this race without a
co-driver I'm not going to lie I'm a
little nervous cuz I've never na myself
what's your strategy for
today uh try not to get dirt in my eyes
all right well best of
luck over in his Camp Chason seems ready
for the Long Haul got up at the Cracker
3 that was it I tried to go back to bed
but I couldn't I was like ah long day
today you know I know it'll only be
7even or 8 hours but it'll be fine yeah
just before the race we got a moment
with last year's winner Raul Gomez is it
extra pressure when you're the king uh a
little bit not bad yeah all right man
good luck thanks
[Music]
man hey are you guys ready to have some
fun out
here are you ready for some a four
racing
5 4 3 2 1 get
it the racers are off the grueling hours
long battle has
begun top speed across flat Dusty
desert slow to a crawl across the
impossibly large
rocks first lap
complete for Bailey the race is
[Music]
over good job Bailey you passed a whole
bunch of cars much so there's only let
me look it
up a short R I think you beat your dad
on lack one no way
yeah on the course two clear leaders
emerge Jason Sherer and Raul
Gomez come on baby come on keep going
keep going keep going baby this is kind
of the end of lap two Jason and R Gomez
are the first two in to pit they're
still neck and neck Jason's had some
better luck with his car maybe some
better
driving Jason you know looks like he
could take this thing if he keeps going
the same way D smart
brother so very very difficult position
for Jason sh to be in after a long day
of racing yeah it's an even more
difficult position when you know that
Ral Gomez is breathing down your neck
and you know that he has a one minute
time advantage on you
what how how close is
it it's a nail biter that's for sure I
don't like nail biters swe just a
[Applause]
moment R Gomez in second only 20 seconds
behind it is tight tight it's going to
come down to seconds not
minutes at the Gomez family pit cautious
optimism look at this look at
this Gomez he comes in now to take the
check a flag spills into
[Applause]
[Music]
celebration just crazy that such a long
race could come down to like such a
tight window and uh feel bad for Jason's
team everyone's a little for laor over
there feel good for the Gomez Brothers
the king is the King
again God damn I try to catch you all
day brother trying to get away I saw you
in the dead I'm like I got him
now oh proud of
[Applause]
[Music]
you out of about 200 competitors only 25
finished Shannon came in hours
later
me I went
home away from the desert in dust
wondering exactly what I just
[Music]
witnessed it was a preview of the
Apocalypse but with
sponsors and people who aren't at least
intentionally trying to kill
you felt a little bit like an outdoor
Vegas felt a little bit like a January
6th on
Wheels it was an incredibly loud Tech
conference it was California with its
open land and car culture and startup
mindset trying to fix impossible
problems it was
America I almost died and I want to go
[Music]
back
oh